[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
surprise surprise everyone asking when
they're gonna drop the Thor trailer they
just drop it out of nowhere so we see
everything from hell the destruction of
Thor's hammer and Hulk vs Thor in the
arena he's a friend of mine we know each
other from work so let's break this down
but if you're new to the channel I do
Marvel and DC every week so be sure to
subscribe to get it there's gonna be a
whole bunch of Thor happening this
summer and I'm doing a giveaway that
I'll explain at the end of the video so
just starting at the beginning of the
trailer working our way to the end so
Thor narrates as he's being dropped down
into hell hell is the domain that hella
as you could imagine rules over she has
the ability to call a portion of
Asgardian souls not every soul because
some of them go to Valhalla the others
go to her there's been several times in
the comics where Thor has been at her
mercy so they might treat it a little
differently in the movies but in the
comics it's like an actual different
plane of existence it's not just like a
planet that you could go fly to the
other option is this could be a stand-in
for fire Lords Surtur's realm which is
like a completely different place from
Asgard but we don't know if he's going
to be in the movie there's just a big
fire demon looking creature in the
concept art they showed at Comic Con so
that is probably where this comes from
but it's either hell or it's Fire Lord
servers realm which are two different
places so you can kind of judge the
timeline of the movie based on Thor's
haircut so when he's being dropped down
in here he has like the full classic
haircut so this is probably earlier in
the movie you see hello walk up with the
torn pants then you see Thor on earth
throw the hammer at her hurt catch it
and destroy it so that explains why he
doesn't have his hammer on Sekar and why
it looks like he has a different version
of his hammer like the ultimate Thor
hammer or even yarr be warned his giant
axe and the other concept art that we've
seen so just expect him to wield a
couple of different weapons during the
movie but I think we all expect him to
get a version of his hammer back by the
end before infinity war really this is
all just to show you how powerful hella
is compared to Thor you have to remember
the reason he's on earth is because he's
looking for Odin he has long hair in the
doctor strange post-credit scene so this
might be some time around that when
they're still looking for him because in
the comics Odin is the one that was
powerful enough to banish hella to hell
so with him absent she runs ramp
all this craziness where it looks like
they almost destroy all of Asgard or
turn it into another version of hell
we can think Loki for that they
explained that as he's been pretending
to be Odin he does such a terrible job
at ruling that she escapes prison and
that's how this happened so it's not
like he purposefully releases her but
he's been trying to be king this whole
time so Thor comes back asks them all
these questions in Tom Hiddleston's like
yeah Loki does not give him a lot of
answers right away but look at Hellas
full headdress here so just like Thor
gets a couple costume changes during the
movie she's gonna get a couple costume
changes to this trash planet is sekar
itself so it's a slightly different
version from the Planet Hulk comics but
this is what the Grandmaster rules over
and this is sort of where the movie goes
Mad Max beyond the Thunderdome where
Valkyrie binds him and it ducks him into
the games she's working with the
Grandmaster but because she's an
Asgardian they have this interesting
relationship like she's been hiding out
on Sekar so it'll be fun to find out why
she chose to work with him in what it is
she's going to do to help Thor and Hulk
escape because we know this is like a
buddy roadtrip movie with Hulk and Thor
but we don't know how much Valkyrie
works with them this shot here's of all
of the Valkyries attacking her her
taking them down that might have
something to do with why the Valkyrie
character is on stack R maybe she's
hiding out she has a weird history with
Asgard because it seems like she's been
there for a while but SIF is supposed to
be in the movie too she might be amongst
these people that are taken down because
I don't know how big her role is I
didn't even think that she was going to
be in the movie but she appears in the
IMDB page so I think Thor's chemistry is
mostly gonna be with Valkyrie like
there's no Jane Foster there's gonna be
no relationship with SIPP as far as
we've seen but he'll it just looks so
badass with her sword here there are a
couple different weapons that she wields
in the comics but the main one is the
knight sword it's made of a room metal
just like Thor's weapons better look
it's a car I love the Trident here in
the background everybody's wondering
when neighboors gonna join the Marvel
Universe there's gonna be a lot of
Easter eggs and I know we're wondering
who some of these helmeted people are
they could be the Eternals because
they're definitely not the Celestials
Loki very clearly sitting with the Grand
Master here on this couch and you look
in the background too and this
definitely looks
like an Easter Egg for Isan the searcher
one of the Celestials but because he's
not 2,000 feet tall like I did the
Celestials Easter Egg video this might
be one of the Eternals because the grand
master is one of the elders of the
universe it would make sense that he be
hanging out with other very powerful
people in the galaxy so we'll see how
they treat those characters in the movie
but the really cool thing about the
Eternals is that they were created by
the Celestials so just more Jack Kirby
stuff and if you look at these designs
in the background too this is also right
out of Jack Kirby this wallpaper looks
so awesome - these designs maybe they'll
start marketing that I feel like
Marvel's production design is so much
better in Phase three so much more
beautiful looking the Grand Master's men
giving him the haircut and we finally
see him Jeff Goldblum as one of the
other elders of the universe the Grand
Master it doesn't seem like he's being
too crazy so we'll see if he has any
tied to the infinity gems but in the
comics he's the one that has the mind
gem they knows has to come take it from
him but we know in the movies that
vision has the mind gem so we'll see but
as an elder of the universe of course he
would know about the infinity gem so
he'll probably have something to say
about it so even though he doesn't
appear anywhere in the trailer just
expect Fano s-- to be somewhere in the
background watching all of this happen I
know a lot of you are wondering if hella
is going to be the stand-in for death
during the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
they actually just paired those two up
in the comics like they're actually a
thing now
Thanos kissing hella because she wants
to get her realm back he can help make
that happen he's all about death she
rules over death so it would make sense
that if they're gonna do that from the
comics then they would try to use stuff
that they're already setting up and
she's one of the most powerful figures
in the MCU now so we'll see about that
she's not confirmed for Infinity Ward
but it would make sense if she's such a
big character that she would pop back up
somewhere because you typically don't
kill villains that are this big but we
finally see Heimdall trying to take down
one of hellas men without his classic
armor on then we see Karl Urban scourge
for the first time who's working with
hella in the comics scourge is one of
the thralls of Amora The Enchantress I
know a lot of you are wondering if she's
in the movie I don't think she is just
because she seems so similar to what
hell is doing in all this
so it's always possible there could be
an easter egg but just a lot of
storylines get compressed and given to
other characters from the comics in the
MCU so hella might be absorbing a lot of
other big characters like death in a
more of the enchantress I just love the
idea of hella making her first escape
and then taking on all of Asgard by
herself main event time so we see Thor
in his full battle gear he's got his
Braveheart makeup on he's got a classic
version of his helmet I love the way he
turns the little wings up like it is in
the comics yet I give you your
Incredible Hulk wearing his Planet Hulk
armor so the cool thing about this in
addition to like the funny moment where
he's like he's my friend from work
talking about the Avenger stuff back on
earth but Holt doesn't seem like he
immediately recognizes Thor so that's
why they're fighting and there is this
bloodlust that Thor gets when he's
fighting it just makes him crazy I'll do
another video about it later this week
because there's a really important
reason why he would bite one of his
friends but the way they talk about Hulk
in this movie is that he's been on Sekar
for a while now fighting in the arena
he's their most popular contender he's
like a god there so it's kind of gone to
his head but in these behind the scenes
pictures they've actually posted him as
banner so for those are you wondering
whether he was going to be in hope for
for the entire movie that should answer
that I'm expecting him to be Hulk for
most of the movie but not everything
like you have the big third act they
don't tease any of that in this we don't
see fire Lords surgery we don't see any
of the other big Ragnarok monsters so
they'll save that for the main trailer
which we might get in another month or
two so we'll see how long it takes most
of this trailer is just meant to hype up
the Planet Hulk elements of the film
Thor versus Hulk hella destroying most
of Asgard and Loki making his flight to
Sekar to find Thor so that they can go
find Odin later in the movie so I'm
expecting them to save some of those big
things like Odin himself all the big
Ragnarok monsters for like that next big
trailer if you're not familiar with the
song they were using during the trailer
- that's Led Zeppelin the immigrant song
so that works on a couple different
levels hella is an immigrant to Asgard
they literally talk about going to
Valhalla the Asgardian version of heaven
so there's just a couple different
reasons they use it in the trailer they
talk about all
Newlands they're gonna be visiting
different corners of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that we've never seen
before in a very cosmic way that's why
they're calling it a roadtrip movie with
Thor and Hulk so let me know what you
guys think of this I can't wait to see
more James Gunn even said that this is
his favorite Marvel trailer from all the
big Marvel movies that are coming out
this year even more favorite than his
own guardians of the galaxy - trailer
which i think is kind of funny believe
all your requests for Thor Ragnarok
videos in the comments below I'll do a
follow-up video in a little while but
there is a new round of the spider-man
giveaway it's for the action figures all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so click here to learn about the big
thor ragnarok Celestials easter-egg and
you can click here to learn all about
Darth Vader's Castle and what's going on
during celebration later this week thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you